DOUG KELLY: Welcome
to our session,
uplevel your data expertise,
professional data engineer
and professional ML
engineer certification.
I'm Doug Kelly and I
now oversee learning
offerings for machine
learning and AI solutions
on Google Cloud.
Previously, I worked as an ML
engineer and data scientist
at Google Cloud and oversaw data
science content at Coursera.
I now spend my time
thinking deeply
about industrializing
machine learning development
on Google Cloud and driving
the creation of training
to prepare learners such as
yourselves for data and machine
learning engineering careers.
In this session, I
would like to start off
by discussing two key data and
machine learning challenges
that enterprises
are facing today.
The gap between data platform
investments and realizing value
from them and the scarcity
and corresponding high demand
for data and machine
learning engineering talent.
This will frame our discussion
on how Google Cloud is
addressing these, both through
data and machine learning
platform innovations as well
as through our industry leading
professional certifications,
the professional data
engineer and professional
ML engineer certifications.
I hold both of
these certifications
and will share my
perspective with you
on the benefits of
these certifications
as well as the
recommended learning
path and resources for each.
Lastly, I will
give you a preview
of what's coming next
for data and machine
learning training from
Google Cloud learning.
My goal for the
session is that you
walk away excited about building
data and machine learning
solutions on Google Cloud
and you start or level
up your learning journey
towards certification today.
One of the bigger
challenges for data teams
is turning into a
competitive advantage
the immense, fast growing,
and fast moving amount of data
that our organizations, our
customers, our partners,
our ecosystem is creating.
According to IDC, 175
zettabytes of data
will be created in
the next five years.
One zetabyte equaling
1 trillion gigabytes--
that's 21 zeros.
Our data production
has more than 10xed
in the last eight years.
In fact, 90% of the
data in the world
has been created in
just the past 10 years.
Yet, when it comes
to turning data
into business outcomes and
business value for companies,
the situation is quite alarming.
Over 2/3 of the data produced
is never actually analyzed.
And almost 70% of
companies say they're
unable to realize tangible and
measurable value from data.
The key takeaway is this,
delivering value with analytics
and machine learning
requires a modern data
platform such as Google Cloud.
Data engineers are essential
to build, operate, and maintain
these data platforms to
enable business value.
And machine learning
engineers, in turn,
build and deploy machine
learning solutions
on top of a robust data platform
to drive decision making
and the realization of value.
Data engineers and ML
engineers work closely together
on data teams to
close the data value
gap by tightly integrating
data and machine
learning infrastructure.
In industry, we know
that machine learning
has had the most business impact
by scaling real-time decision
making and personalization.
That means we have to act fast.
To do so, we need data engineers
enabling data processing
and analytics speed
and ML engineers
to deliver predictions that
arrive at the point of action
and real time.
That's the difference between
discovering and preventing
fraud, purchases and
cart abandonment,
and proactive and
reactive customer service.
Google Cloud is simplifying data
analytics and machine learning
through each of
the platform design
pillars outlined on this slide.
We deliver serverless
analytics, allowing customers
to keep development velocity
high and their focus purely
on analytics versus
infrastructure.
We offer a comprehensive set
of data analytics workloads,
from batch and streaming data
processing to data warehousing
to business intelligence.
We provide the services
for our customers
to operationalize machine
learning solutions,
from pre-built ML APIs to
AutoML to BigQuery ML to custom
TensorFlow and PyTorch models.
We enable the best open source
data technologies to give you
flexibility and choice.
And we build for enterprise data
and machine learning workloads
at any scale.
Google Cloud is already a
recognized industry leader
with a purpose built, end-to-end
data analytics and machine
learning platform to support
the entire data team anywhere,
on premise or on Google Cloud.
Data engineers are able to
leverage services like Pub/Sub,
Dataflow, and Data Fusion to
ingest, prepare, and transform
data at any scale.
They can also leverage
new data services
like data plaques and
analytics hub and market
leading analytics services,
such as BigQuery and Looker,
to manage and quickly
surface enterprise data
sets and insights to
the entire organization.
Announced at Google
I/O this year,
Vertex AI is also rolling
out as the successor
to AI platform for machine
learning development.
It provides ML engineers with
an integrated suite of services
to help enable each stage
of your ML workflow,
from gathering data to feature
engineering to building models
and, finally, deploying
and moderneering
these models in production.
For example, new
Vertex MLop services,
like Pipelines
and Feature Store,
give ML engineers
reusable ML workflows
while Vertex Predictions
gives ML engineers
a scalable, serverless
solution to get
model predictions into
decision making UIs faster.
Depending upon how you define
the machine learning market,
if you look at platforms like
Qwiklabs, Kaggle, Coursera,
and LinkedIn, there
are only about 300,000
global professional data
engineers, data scientists,
and ML engineers today.
Yet, at the same time, there's
huge demand for data engineers
and ML engineers in the market.
According to Coursera
market research,
in just the past
12 months, there's
been over 200,000 job postings
requiring data engineering
and ML engineering
skills, and that demand
has been trending upwards.
Over the past three
years, there's
been a 91% increase in job
postings requiring these skill
sets.
Many enterprises are
still in the early stages
of data platform
modernization and AI adoption
and are really struggling to
find data engineers and ML
engineers to make this happen.
To bridge the skills gap, Google
Cloud learning has brought some
of the best of Google
together, its top engineers,
it's solutions and expertise
in building large scale data
and machine learning systems
to produce two industry leading
certifications in the job
market, the professional data
engineer and
professional ML engineer.
These certifications are
not just about Google Cloud
technologies.
In fact, the initial stages of
designing each certification
are product agnostic.
And just like the
real world examinees
are expected to
know the vast amount
of foundational concepts, design
patterns, and technology trade
offs that they may encounter
in their day to day jobs.
So how have these certifications
been received by learners
and recognized in
the job market?
Think of Google
Cloud certifications
as valuable tools to
validate your learning
and help you build your career,
get promoted, and earn raises.
In a recent survey of Google
Cloud certified individuals
conducted by an
independent third party,
we heard some incredible
pieces of feedback
from learners across the job
market on how Google Cloud
certifications have enabled and
boosted skills for Cloud roles.
78% of respondents
were more confident
when talking about their
future opportunities
after certification.
82% of respondents felt
proud to have a proof
point about their
skills and abilities
when working with recruiters.
83% of respondents told us
they felt more marketable.
And finally, 85%
of respondents just
had the boost of confidence
that they both wanted
and needed to really
get themselves out there
for Cloud opportunities.
So in short, if you're asking
yourself, what's in it for me,
I hope these anecdotal
shares and statistics drive
home how learners
like yourselves
have benefited from Google
Cloud certifications.
Next, let's take a
look a little bit more
closely at the
value propositions
for the professional data
engineer and ML engineer
certifications.
First, let's talk about the
professional data engineer
certification.
A professional data
engineer is the enabler
of data driven decision making
by collecting, transforming,
and publishing data.
This is an intermediate
professional certification
that requires three-plus
years of industry experience
and one-plus years
designing and managing
data solutions on Google Cloud.
We offer a data
engineering learning
path with hands-on
practice through Qwiklabs
that culminates in a
two hour multiple choice
and multi select exam
to validate your ability
to design, build, and
operationalize data processing
systems.
Upon completion, you earn a
shareable credential and gain
access to Google Cloud
community, swag, and events.
So why do I think you should
get certified as a Google Cloud
data engineer?
Data engineering is a
challenging applied discipline
that is best learned
through practice.
Through following the
recommended learning path,
you will complete 30 plus
hands on data engineering labs
in a sandbox GCP
project environment
to practice building
and deploying
data processing solutions.
Further, the Google Cloud
data engineer certification
was recently named
as the number one
top paid global IT certification
according to global knowledge
market research.
You will learn some of the
most valuable and in-demand
enterprise skills
in the market and be
indispensable to organizations
modernizing their data
platforms and looking to
adopt machine learning.
Third, you will learn data
engineering best practices
from Google, which brought
Hadoop and Beam to the world
and currently processes over
2.5 exabytes of logs per
month on planet scale
compute in network.
Through this certification,
you will differentiate yourself
for career success by learning
how to choose the right data
storage and processing services,
identify the right balance
of trade offs for
various data workloads,
and practice implementing
production tested data
processing design patterns.
To prepare you for the exam,
we designed a learning path
that covers foundational
data concepts
and data pipeline design
patterns as well as
steps you progressively through
key data ingestion, storage,
and data transformation
services on Google Cloud.
For aspiring data
engineers, the learning path
is designed to be completed
in about three and 1/2 months
and about five hours per week.
For existing data engineers,
the Coursera preparation
certificate is
still a great place
to start to learn Google Cloud
data services that you can then
supplement as needed with
additional hands-on practice
through Qwiklabs.
I recommend the certification
to ML engineers, as well,
and personally started
my certification journey
here first.
Data management
and data processing
are key foundations of modern
production ML pipelines.
Now, let's discuss the
professional ML engineer
certification.
This is a more
advanced certification
that also recommends three-plus
years of industry experience
as a data scientist or
machine learning engineer,
including at least one
year designing and managing
machine learning
solutions on Google Cloud.
A professional ML
engineer designs, builds,
and production houses ML models
to solve business challenges
using Google Cloud ML services
and knowledge of proven ML
models and techniques.
So why do I think you should get
certified as a Google Cloud ML
engineer?
The Google Cloud professional
ML engineer certification
is continuously updated by
leading Googler and industry
subject matter experts to
best reflect the ML engineer
skill set in the job market.
This gives aspiring and
current ML engineers
the opportunity to validate
their expertise in machine
learning in Google Cloud against
a rigorous, practical industry
benchmark exam recognized
in the job market.
Google is a globally
recognized leader
in AI research and
applied machine learning
with over a decade of
experience productionizing
machine learning systems as
part of applications serving
billions of users per day.
Google Cloud is the
platform by which
Google delivers this pioneering
ML research and product
solutions to customers.
In fact, Google
Cloud's AI platform
was recognized by Gartner as
an industry leader in its 2020
Magic Quadrant for Cloud
AI developer services.
My key takeaways on the ML
engineer certification for you
all are this.
The Google Cloud professional
ML engineering certification
is a rewarding learning
journey for you
to build your development skills
on an industry-leading data
and machine learning platform to
both differentiate yourself as
well as position yourself
for success in the rapidly
evolving field of
applied machine learning.
The learning path is designed
to augment your study
through a structured progression
of role based curriculum
through Google
Cloud fundamentals
through applied machine learning
and up to ML ops content.
It's designed to be completed
in about four months
at about six hours per week.
The content is
available on demand
through a Coursera professional
certification certificate
with additional hands-on
practice opportunities
available through Qwiklabs.
For aspiring ML engineers,
I have two additional tips
for you.
First, take advantage of $300
in free credits in the Google
Cloud free tier on products
such as the ML APIs AutoML
and BigQuery to start building
ML applications today.
Second, learn
socially and publicly.
Form a study group to share
your learnings and projects
with others.
GitHub, blogs, or the
Google Cloud learning forums
are a great place to start.
I personally like open
source contributions
to projects, tutorials,
and documentation.
Take a look at open issues on
some of your favorite email
projects like TensorFlow
and Google Cloud samples
tagged as help-wanted
or good first issue
as an approachable
place to dive in.
Lastly, I'd like to share
with you all of what's
coming next for Google Cloud
data and machine learning
training.
It's an exciting time to be
building data and machine
learning solutions.
So far in 2021, Google Cloud's
already industry leading data
and machine learning
platform has
seen its most significant
enhancements in the past two
to three years.
In the June 2021 data summit,
Google Cloud engineering teams
laid out their vision
for the data cloud
with new services like
Dataplex and Analytics Hub
to bring new data management and
analytics sharing capabilities
to enterprise data teams.
Together, along with new
integrations between BigQuery
and Booker, data engineers can
focus on further breaking down
organizational data silos
to more broadly socialize
insights across organizations
to enable business value.
Furthermore, at
Google IO in May 2021,
Google Cloud
announced Vertex AIs,
the successor to AI Platform,
a unification of services
such as AutoML and
custom training
for developing ML
solutions faster.
There are over 20-plus major
updates and net new services
reaching GA over the next
year, particularly related
to ML ops, opening up
fundamentally new ways
to build and deploy ML
solutions and incorporate them
into decision making systems
to deliver business value.
Vertex AI, BigQuery,
and Looker, as well as
AI industry solutions empower
data scientists or data
engineers and ML
engineers with new tools
to close the data value gap
while enhancing development
and productivity, the ability
to scale your workflow
and your decision
making with your data,
as well as accelerating
time to value.
My colleagues and I in
Cloud Learning services
are hard at work bringing Data
Cloud, Vertex AI, and industry
solutions content to you
through Qwiklabs and Coursera.
Stay tuned for
significant new data
and machine learning
training rolling out
in the second half of
this year as well as
a major update to the
professional ML engineer
certification for Vertex AI
in the second half of 2022.
Now, I'm keen to switch over
to the Google Cloud console
to share with you some of the
new capabilities of Vertex AI.
Welcome to the Vertex AI
ML development platform
in the Google Cloud console.
To get started, first
enable the Vertex service
in the API and Services tab.
Vertex AI is a platform
that contains services
for each phase of the ML
development lifecycle,
from data sets to
predictions, enabling
you to go from experimentation
to production ML
workflows to delivering
business value faster.
The Data Sets tab contains
a list of all your data
sets in your project with
support for image, tabular,
text, and video data types.
Manage data sets enable you to
create a link between your data
sets and your models for
traceable and reproducible
experiments.
You also get descriptive
statistics on your data set
as well as the ability to
configure automatic or custom
data splitting.
The Notebooks tab contains new
features such as Managed Vertex
Notebooks.
Vertex Notebooks are interactive
JupyterLab development
environments that enable
you to quickly build custom
machine learning solutions.
They provide support
for multiple frameworks
flexible compute and easy
access to accelerators
like GPUs and TPUs.
They also have newer,
tighter integrations
with key Google
Cloud data services,
like Cloud Storage and
BigQuery in a single window.
Check out some of the newer
integrations with Data PROC
as well, which also
makes Vertex notebooks
a great single window for
development of Apache spark,
as well.
In the Training tab you can also
see and create your training
pipelines using the same
managed data set for both AutoML
and custom training jobs.
You can leverage pre-built
containers with your model code
with frameworks like TensorFlow,
Scikit-learn, PyTorch,
or XGBoost.
For maxima; flexibility,
you can also
leverage custom containers, as
well, leverage in any framework
you'd like with any
additional dependencies,
upload it to artifact
registry, and use it
for model, training, prediction,
or as a pipeline step.
AutoML is a great way to quickly
build highly accurate models
with built-in support for
standard evaluation metrics,
feature attributions,
quick model deployment,
as well as metadata that
covers the model architecture
search as well as the
hyperparameters that
were searched, as well.
In the Experiments tab, you can
create a managed TensorBoard
instance to organize and compare
model performance across model
runs and data splits.
For predictions, you
can deploy new endpoints
for online predictions
or scheduled batch jobs
for bulk predictions, as well.
A model can be deployed
to multiple endpoints
or can serve multiple
models on a single endpoint.
With multiple models on a single
endpoint and traffic splitting
capabilities, you now have some
new model prediction evaluation
capabilities, such
as A/B testing.
For production ML workflows,
the new Vertex pipeline service
enables you to automate,
monitor, and govern
your machine learning systems
by orchestrating your tasks
in a serverless manner.
Clicking into an
individual pipeline run,
you have a graphical
user interface
to view and debug each
step of your workflow,
from data set creation,
model training, evaluation,
and deployment.
You can expand
upon your artifacts
to be able to deep dive
into individual pipeline
runs and their artifacts, such
as model evaluation metrics.
In this example, you also have
a conditional model deployment
step, which you
can use to ensure
that you're only pushing
higher performing
models to production.
This concludes a
quick walkthrough
of just some of the new
features available in Vertex AI.
I encourage you
to also check out
services like data labeling,
ML metadata for tracking
your development artifacts
across your project,
as well as the upcoming
Feature Store, which
enables you to reuse
features across ML use cases.
For hands-on on practice in a
Google Cloud project with some
of the features I just
introduced, check out
the Vertex AI labs on Qwiklabs.
A great place to start is
the Vertex AI Qwik Start,
where you will walk through
an end-to-end custom training
workflow on Vertex AI
to train and deploy
a TensorFlow model to predict
customer lifetime value.
To start your data and
machine learning engineering
learning journeys today, check
out our recently launched
Google Cloud Skills
Boost, our new destination
for Google Cloud learning with
over 700 labs and courses.
This will be available to you
all the entire month of October
free of charge.
It's never been a more
exciting and productive time
to be building data systems and
doing applied machine learning.
Thank you for learning with us.